الزلزال دمار وماساه وما يليه من ايام هي
تحدي الحياه الجديده ونتحدث هنا عن
مليونير تركي نزحوا الى الشمال بحثا عن
ملجا او على الاقل الابتعاد عن المناطق
التي ضربتها الزلازل نزوح الملايين نحو
الشمال رافقه نزوح سوري في الاتجاه
المعاكس رغم ان العثور على خيمه او غطاء
قد يصبح حلما في سوريا الا انهم اختاروا
العوده بعد ان بات اللجوء عاجزا عن
احتوائهم تحالف الحرب والسياسه والطبيعه
اجبرهم على بناء حياتهم للمره الثالثه
معبر باب الهوى تحول الى شاهد على عوده
السوريين قبل سنوات غادر السوريون طلبا
للامان اشهر اللجوء تحولت الى سنوات
وتركيا تحولت الى وطن ثاني شيدوا فيه
بيوتهم واسسوا تجاره او امتحنوا الحرف لكن
اندماجهم لم ي الكثير ومع اقتراب
الانتخابات تحول السوريون الى ورقه سياسيه
انقر هذه المره اعلنت نيتها باعادتهم قبل
ان يرفع الزلزال مشاعر معاداه السوريين
تركيا للاتراك شعار تبناه تبنته المؤسسات
التركيه كما المواطنين البسطاء السوريون
تم توجيههم في خيام تابعه لمنظمه افاد عكس
الاتراك الذين خصصت لهم بيوت مؤقته
السوريون وصفوا الخيام بقدرهم المحتوم ولا
فائده من الهروب من العراء الى العراء
وبالتالي مناخ سوريا سيكون ارحم قليلا الا
ان البرد ايضا يقتل هناك وجاء دور الاوبئه
لتفتك بالسوريين غياب البنيه التحتيه ادى
لانتشار الكوليرا بينما سجل مركز ايواء
المنكوبين في حلب وحدها مئه الف حاله تسمم
غذائي
متعودين نشتغل نترزق الله وقال
حمامات ولا ميت قطعت وكهرباء
الشعب التركي دائما في شعب عنصري الشعب
العنصري يعني دائما موجود بكل شعب بكل
مجتمع في شعب عنصري اما من ضمن المناطق
الزلزال احنا ضمن المناطق انطاكيا كهرمان
مرعش الماضي فيها شوي الشعب التركي
الله
والله يحمي هالشعب وهالبلد ويرجعنا لبلدنا
ظلم ظلم
ظلم ظلم ظلمنا في سوريا وانظلمنا